ANNOUNCER: The following content
is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
HERBERT GROSS: Hi, our lecture
today is entitled
differentiation of inverse
functions.
And it pulls together
two previous
topics that we've discussed.
Namely, inverse functions
themselves, and secondly, the
chain rule that we've
discussed just
a short time ago.
And perhaps the best way to
introduce the power of
differentiation of inverse
functions is to start out with
such a problem.
Let's actually try to
differentiate a particular
function, which at least up
until now, we have not been
able to differentiate.
The function happens to be y
equals the cube root of 'x'.
In other words, 'y' equals
'x to the 1/3'.
Let's find 'dy dx' if 'y'
equals 'x to the 1/3'.
Now, the whole idea of inverse
functions is what?
That it gives us a chance
to paraphrase.
That we can interchange the role
of the dependent and the
independent variables.
And like any other form of
paraphrase, even though two
things may be synonymous,
psychologically one of the two
may be easier for us to
visualize than the other.
In particular, in this
particular case, if 'y' equals
'x to the 1/3', another way
of writing the same
thing is to say what?
'x' equals 'y cubed'.
And now, given that 'x' equals
'y cubed', in other words,
with treating 'x' as a function
of 'y', we certainly
know how to differentiate 'y
cubed' with respect to 'y'.
Namely, we know that for
a positive exponent to
differentiate, all we have to do
is bring the exponent down
and replace it by one less.
In other words, right away what
we can say is that 'dx
dy' is '3y squared'.
Now if we use the result of last
time that we talked about
when we were discussing the
chain rule, and I'll review
that result in just
a few moments.
But for the time being, let's
assume that we have the result
that 'dx dy' is the reciprocal
of 'dy dx'.
In other words, if 'dy dx' is
'1 over 'dx dy'', that tells
us that 'dy dx' is '1
over 3y squared'.
And I guess to write that in a
more convenient form, that's
'1/3 y to the minus
2' if you're used
to exponential notation.
If we now recall from above that
'y' is equal to 'x to the
1/3', this can now be written
as ''1/3 x to the 1/3'
to the minus 2'.
And we now arrive at an answer
'dy dx' is '1/3 x
to the minus 2/3'.
By the way, let me point out
there certainly was nothing
wrong with leaving our answer
in this particular form.
It's just conventional that
wherever possible, if the
original problem was given as
a function of 'x', we would
like our answer to also
be a function of 'x'.
I mean, here for example, we
could have said that the
answer is '1/3 y to the
minus 2', where 'y'
equals 'x to the 1/3'.
All we've done here is to fill
this thing in explicitly.
By the way, there may have
been a tendency--
and here's an example of
circular reasoning.
There may have been a tendency
to say, didn't we already
learn that to differentiate a
power, we just bring the power
down and replace
it by one less?
In other words, if we did that
bringing down the 1/3 would
give us a factor of
1/3 in front.
Replacing 1/3 by one less,
1/3 minus 1 is minus 2/3.
We would then see that 'dy
dx' should be '1/3 x
to the minus 2/3'.
Which is exactly what
we got this way.
The point that we should mention
at this particular
stage is that the derivative of
'x' to the 'n' being 'nx to
the 'n - 1'' was proven only
for the case that 'n' is an
integer, either positive
or negative.
One uses the binomial theorem
to prove the result for a
positive integer.
One uses the quotient rule
to prove the result for a
negative integer.
And now, even though I didn't
do this thing in general, I
think you can see how this
will generalize.
For fractional exponents,
one uses the
inverse function idea.
Namely, we did have to use the
fact that if 'y' is equal to
'x to the 1/3', 'x' equals
'y cubed' was
an equivalent equation.
And we could differentiate
that.
Now, what is the hang up here,
in so far as how certain are
we that 'dy dx' and 'dx
dy' are reciprocals?
You may recall that when we used
the chain rule, we showed
that if 'y' is a differentiable
function of
'x', and if 'x' is a
differentiable function of
'u', then 'y' is a
differentiable function of 'u'.
And in particular, 'dy du' is
''dy dx' times 'dx du''.
And if we now take the
particular case where the
first variable equals
the third, way 'u'
equals 'y', we get what?
'dy dy', which is 1, equals
''dy dx' times 'dx dy''.
And at first glance, it might
seem that we've proven
rigorously now the result that
'dx dy' and 'dy dx' are
reciprocals of each other.
Product is 1.
The one logical hang up
that we have right
now is simply this.
In the statement of the chain
rule, it did not say that 'y'
had to be a function of
'x' and 'x' had to be
a function of 'u'.
It said 'y' had to be a
differentiable function of 'x'.
That was the first variable
had to be a differentiable
function of the second.
And the second had to
be a differentiable
function of the third.
In other words, coming down to
here, if we know that 'y' is a
differentiable function of 'x'
and 'y' has an inverse
function, and if we also knew
that the inverse function was
differentiable.
See, in other words, this must
be a differentiable function
of this and this must be a
differentiable function of this.
In other words, the one point
that was missing was is that
if we knew that if a function
is differentiable, then its
inverse if it exists, is
also differentiable.
The chain rule would have given
us a rigorous proof.
The point that we're missing
though is we do not as yet
know that the inverse of a
differentiable function is
also a differentiable
function.
Now if you recall on our earlier
lecture on inverse
functions, we pointed out that
there was a rather interesting
graphical interpretation between
'y' equals 'f of x'
and 'y' equals 'f
inverse of x'.
By the way whenever I say, you
may recall, that's just my
polite way of saying perhaps
you don't, but you'd better
look it up because we had it.
So recall that the two curves
are symmetric with respect to
the line 'y' equals 'x'.
By the way again, just
a brief aside here.
Notice that either one of these
functions could have
been called 'f of x' and the
other one could have been
called 'f inverse'.
In other words, just another
piece of brief knowledge here
that the inverse of the inverse
is the original
function again.
In other words, thinking in
terms of our function machine,
if you interchanged the input
and the output, and then of
the resulting machine again,
interchange the input and the
output, you're back to the
original machine again.
So in this particular diagram, I
certainly could have labeled
this curve 'y' equals 'f of x'
or 'g of x', then this curve
here would have been 'y' equals
'g inverse of x'.
But the important
point is what?
That 'y' equals 'f of x' and
'y' equals 'f inverse of x'
are symmetric with respect
to the line 'y equals x'.
Now you see we have a
particularly simple geometric
argument as to why an inverse
function should be
differentiable if the original
function is differentiable.
Namely, pictorially, what does
it mean to say that a function
is differentiable?
It means that when you
plot its graph,
the graph is smooth.
In other words, if 'f' is a
differentiable function, the
curve 'y' equals 'f of x'
will be a smooth curve.
Now simply ask yourself the
following question.
If you take a smooth curve and
take its mirror image with
respect to the line 'y' equals
'x', or for that matter with
respect to any line,
do you expect the
curve to become un-smooth?
You see, in other words, the
mirror image of a smooth curve
will again, be smooth.
And that's perhaps the most
intuitive way of picking off
in your mind why if a function
is differentiable, its inverse
function will also be
differentiable.
Of course, as we've seen many
times already in this course,
we must distinguish between
geometric intuition and
mathematical analysis.
That on more occasions than
one, what seemed to be
happening geometrically was
complicated by something
unforeseen when we tried to get
the results in terms of
analytic methods.
Let me give you an illustration
of this.
You see, what we're really
saying is, granted that a
picture can be a good visual
aid, let's suppose we're given
the curve 'y' equals
'f inverse of x'.
Well, first of all, what is
that the same as saying?
It's the same as saying that
'x' equals 'f of y'.
At any rate, the question
is this.
We're assuming that 'f' is a
differentiable function.
What we would like to do is to
prove that 'f inverse' is also
differentiable.
Now you see the whole thing
again is that whenever you
want to prove anything, what
do you mean if you take 'f
inverse' and differentiate it?
And by the way, that may look
like a funny notation.
Think of 'f inverse' as
being one symbol.
Call it 'g'.
Call it whatever you want.
All we're saying is, how would
we, by definition, find the
derivative of the inverse
function say,
at 'x' equals 'x1'?
And the answer is that by
definition, it's just what?
It's the limit as 'delta
x' approaches 0.
Same definition as before.
''f of 'x1 plus 'delta
x' minus 'f of
x1'' over 'delta x'.
And in fact, if you want to
write that a little bit more
explicitly, what is another
way of writing 'delta x'?
'Delta x', of course, is ''x1
plus 'delta x' minus x1'.
Now the idea is--
this is 'f inverse'.
See we want to find the
derivative of 'f inverse'.
Who cares what the name
of the function is?
Whatever the name of the
function is, what do you do?
You compute the function at 'x1
plus 'delta x', subtract
off its value at 'x1', and
divide by 'delta x'.
So by the same definition that
we had the first time we
defined derivative, this is
the basic definition for
finding the derivative
of 'f inverse'.
Now, how do we use the
fact that we already
know what 'f' is like?
Remember, we mentioned when we
talked about inverse functions
before is at the
time you use--
the way you really effectively
handle inverse functions is
when you know properties of
the original function.
We're not just working blindly
with 'f inverse' here, we're
working with the case that 'f
inverse' is the inverse of the
function 'f', and that we know
that 'f' is differentiable.
And now we want to see if
knowing that 'f' is
differentiable, can we prove
that 'f inverse' is
differentiable?
And you see, the idea is not
really that difficult.
We can work this thing out step
by step from out little
diagram over here.
You see, notice that another
name for 'f inverse of 'x1
plus 'delta x'' is 'y1
plus delta y'.
Let me just work with what's
in the bracketed
expression over here.
See, the numerator is
'y1 plus 'delta y'.
That's this term.
Now, what's 'f inverse of x1'?
As we come up over here,
remember the curve is 'y'
equals 'f inverse'.
So 'f inverse of x1'
is just 'y1'.
Now what's our denominator?
'x1 plus 'delta x' maps into
'y1 plus 'delta y'.
Well, the idea is this.
In terms of inverse functions,
'x1 plus 'delta x' is just the
back map of 'y1 plus
'delta y'.
In other words, since
'f inverse'--
let's write that down.
Since 'f inverse of 'x1 plus
'delta x' is equal to 'y1 plus
'delta y', that's another
way of saying that
'x1 plus 'delta x'--
we might as well write this
because this is what we're
emphasizing.
In other words, this
becomes what?
'x1 plus 'delta x' is just 'f
of 'y1 plus 'delta y''.
And 'x1' is just 'f of y1'.
See again, I used the picture
as a visual aid.
But notice that everything I've
written down here follows
analytically by my basic
definitions.
I don't want to overwhelm you
with formal proofs here.
These are all done
in the text.
And I think that again, for
those of you who are
proof-oriented, the proofs are
done excellently enough so
that you'll get them
from that.
And for those of you who are not
proof-oriented, an extra
few minutes here will not make
that much of a difference.
But what I want you to see over
here is how this thing
starts to set up now.
In other words, notice that this
starts to look like what?
Let me just come over here where
we have some more space.
This is what?
The limit as 'delta
x' approaches 0.
'f 'delta y' over ''f
of 'y1 plus delta
y' minus 'f of y1''.
And see, if you look at this
thing, remember 'f' is a
differentiable function
of 'y'.
If this had been a 'delta y'
approaching 0, this would have
just been what?
If we could assume that as
'delta x' approaches 0, 'delta
y' approaches 0, this just
would have been what?
This is the reciprocal of the
derivative of 'f of y' with
respect to 'y'.
In other words, this would be
what one would call 'dx dy'
evaluated at 'y' equals 'y1'.
This is what?
''f of 'y1 plus delta y' minus
'f of y1'' over 'delta y' as
'delta y' approaches 0
is that derivative.
And we have what?
The reciprocal of this thing.
And in other words, what we will
have proven is that 'dy
dx' evaluated at 'x' equals
'x1' is the same as the
reciprocal of 'dx dy' evaluated
at 'y' equals 'y1'.
The only thing we have to be
sure of in terms of the formal
proof is to make sure that as
'delta x' approaches 0, 'delta
y' approaches 0.
And that is not too difficult
a thing to do.
As I say, the proof is
done in the book.
We could do it here, but I think
that that would take
away from the flavor of what
we're trying to show.
The idea is it's fine to think
in terms of intuitive ideas.
In fact, to level with you as
much as I can, of all of my
mathematician friends who are
outstanding in various aspects
of mathematics, to my knowledge
not one of them
works without some sort of
mental picture as to
what's going on.
In other words, you can take
something that's very, very
abstract and somehow or other,
you associate in your mind
some kind of a visual aid
that gives you a hint as
to what to do next.
But once you know what to do
next, you always formulate the
thing in terms of mathematical
precision.
In other words, another way of
looking at this-- let's give
this a broad title.
Let's call this 'Proof
versus Intuition'.
And this is a topic that comes
up very, very early in
mathematics.
Perhaps the first place that
it's extremely noticeable is
in the subject called
plane geometry.
Let me give you a
for instance.
Let's take a typical
traditional
plane geometry problem.
We'l take an isosceles
triangle ABC,
with AB equal to AC.
And what we would like to prove
is that the base angles
of this triangle are equal.
We'd like to prove that angle
B equals angle C.
Now you remember how you tackled
this problem in high
school geometry.
You said something like this.
Well, let me draw the
angle bisector here.
That meets BC at D. AD equals
itself by identity.
These two angles are equal by
definition of angle bisector.
Therefore, triangle ABD is
congruent to triangle ACD.
And corresponding pots of
congruent triangles are equal.
And you then proved that the
base angles of an isosceles
triangle were equal.
Now, at this stage of the game
if you were anything like me,
what you would have done
has said, this is
the end of the problem.
Let's go onto the next one.
But if you had passed this in
this particular way, you would
have got a 0.
And why'd you get a 0?
Well, if you remember from plane
geometry, there was a
particular format that
had to be followed.
It was called the statement
reason format.
For every statement that
you wrote down, you
had to give a reason.
And the reason couldn't be
things like because, or why
not, or obvious.
The reasons had to be what?
Either definitions, or rules, or
previously proven theorems.
In other words, notice that
even though we never
emphasized it, back in plane
geometry when you were drawing
this diagram and getting the
result, that was the geometric
intuition part.
In other words, this was
where you showed
the result was plausible.
The logic part--
and this is why geometry is
being stressed particularly in
the modern curriculum.
In terms of logic, notice that
once you had your intuitive
picture, the statement reason
part followed independently of
the picture.
You used the picture to set
yourself up, but the final
proof hinged on what?
Having the result follow
purely from the axioms
themselves.
From the assumptions.
And by the way, this is the
basic difference between
traditional and modern
geometry.
In modern geometry, let's go
back to the same proof.
And it's a rather interesting
point and I think you'll see a
connection between what's
happening in geometry and
what's happening in calculus.
You see, remember how
we proved this.
We said draw the angle bisector
and call this point
D. And then we went through
this and got this result.
In modern geometry
they say look it.
Without looking at the picture,
how do you know that
D falls between B and C?
It's obvious in the picture
that it does.
But if everything has to follow
inescapably from your
rules when you go through the
statement reason part, then
unless you have some rule or
definition that tells you that
D must fall between B and C,
you can't use this result.
In other words, your result
will be plausible from a
picture, but not provable
analytically
So in modern geometry, we
add a few axioms, a few
rules of the game.
They're called the axioms of
betweenness, the axioms of
separation.
How one point separates other
points and what this thing
means analytically, so that we
can continue on this way.
Now you see what I'm driving
at is simply this.
The Utopian way I think of
learning is to first have an
intuitive picture of
what's going on.
Then you proceed gradually to
learn what rigor means.
As I may have said to you
before, in the language of
functions, rigor is a function
of the 'rigoree'.
In other words, if a person is
perfectly willing to accept a
result, and he's not going to
get into any trouble using it,
let him use the intuitive
result.
On the other hand, if you wanted
to teach him later that
there are pitfalls using his
intuition as a background,
then we can come ahead and start
to do things in a little
bit more of a sophisticated
manner.
Now, you see what I'm driving
at I guess is this.
If a youngster survives this
procedure of going from the
intuitive approach to the
rigorous approach to the
logical difference between
analysis and geometry, he'll
be in great shape when
he gets to calculus.
You see, the idea is
exactly the same.
What we're saying in the
calculus is simply this.
Given the derivative of an
inverse function, we do it
first in a way that makes good
geometric sense to us.
Then to make sure that the
results do not depend on our
picture, and that our results
can be generalized to more
variables or to tougher analytic
situations where we
can't draw the picture, then
we tried to pick up the
sophistication that allows us to
remove the picture proceed
purely by analysis.
What I'm telling you as you read
the text is if you can do
both, fine.
Learn the proofs and
the intuition.
If you have trouble with the
proofs, at least satisfy
yourself that they're there.
That they do seem to follow
from the basic axioms and
other assumptions.
But meanwhile, rely heavily
on the intuitive results.
And the important thing being
that you have a picture as to
what's going on.
The second aside that
I'd like to make--
and in fact, I would like to
conclude our lesson for today
with this very important
aside--
is the following.
You remember when we were first
learning limits and we
talked about--
well, let me just make
an aside right at
the beginning here.
Hate to do that, but it
just occurred to me.
Remember when we said, let's
compute the limit of 'f of x'
as 'x' approaches 'a'.
And our first approach was to
say, OK, let's just replace
'x' by 'a'.
And you said, OK, this is fine,
but what happens if you
get a 0/0 form?
And the counterargument to that
was, well, if 'f' and 'a'
are chosen at random, how likely
is it that we're going
to get a 0/0 form?
Answer's well, it's not
too likely at all.
And then the answer to that
was, well, but look it.
Every time you take a
derivative, you're going to
get a 0/0 form.
And so the question
was, in calculus
0/0 was very important.
Now we're going to ask the same
kind of a question about
1:1 functions.
I guess the best way to
state it is bluntly.
How likely is it that a given
function f is 1:1?
For example, if I draw a curve
like this, is this graph 1:1?
The answer, of course, is no.
For example, if I pick the point
'y1' over here and come
across here, I find at least
in this picture, three
different candidates, three
different "x's".
'x1', 'x2', and 'x3'
for which what?
'f of x1' equals 'f of x2',
equals 'f of x3' equals 'y1'.
And at first glance, you might
be tempted to say, oops, we
can't apply any of our theory
to this particular function.
But here's the very
important point.
Very often in calculus we do not
start with 'y1' and look
to see whether we have
'x1', 'x2', or 'x3'.
Very often in calculus we're
starting at something like,
oh, for the sake of
argument, 'x3'.
And we say, hey, I wonder
what's going on in a
neighborhood of 'x3'.
If you want a fancy word to take
care of that, it's what
the mathematician calls the
difference between local and
global properties.
And those words are exactly
what they sound like.
Local means in a neighborhood
of a point and global means
let's look at the curve
in the large.
And the point is this.
That very, very often in
calculus, we are not
interested in what's
happening globally.
For example, when you're driving
in a car and you're
driving along say, the New York
Thruway, and you're near
Albany and somebody says, what's
our gas situation?
Somehow or other, what your
gas situation was when you
were near Buffalo has no bearing
on the problem here.
How full the gas tank is and the
problems involved with a
full gas tank are local
properties.
And whether this gets more
abstract or not is irrelevant.
All we're saying is that in
calculus, very often you're
dealing with a neighborhood
of a point.
And notice this, and we'll
do is intuitively.
The book again, supplies
the rigorous proof.
Notice that if 'f prime
of x3' here is not 0.
Well, for the sake of argument,
in this case, we
notice that the curve
is always rising.
Notice that with a smooth curve,
if it's rising at a
particular point, obviously it's
going to be rising in a
neighborhood of that point.
Just look at the picture here.
And what we're saying is this.
What does it mean for a
function to be 1:1?
For a function to be 1:1 on an
interval, it's sufficient that
either 'f prime' never be
negative, or 'f prime' never
be positive.
In other words, what
it means is this.
That as long as the derivative
is not 0, we can find a
neighborhood, a local
neighborhood, that will make
that function 1:1 on that
particular neighborhood.
In other words, once I'm working
with this particular
neighborhood, and I can't
stress this point enough
because it's going to come
up over and over again.
It's going to come up in more
sophisticated forms when we
deal with functions of
several variables.
But the idea is what?
That in a neighborhood of a
point where the derivative is
not 0, the function may be
viewed as being 1:1.
You see, the tough part is that
if you start with 'y1',
you have no way of knowing just
from that whether you
want a neighborhood near
'x1', or 'x2', or 'x3'.
But if you know what
neighborhood you want, in a
sufficiently small neighborhood,
the function
always behaves like it's 1:1.
In fact, the only problem that
one runs into is the case
where at the point in question,
the derivative is 0.
And I think you can see
pictorially what happens in
that case right away.
As soon as the derivative is 0,
notice that no matter how
small an interval-- well, I
shouldn't say this is a
possibility.
Let me show you what
I mean by that.
Suppose the curve has
a low point here.
What I'm saying is if the
curve does this, then no
matter how small an interval
we choose surrounding 'x1',
the function will not be
1:1 in that interval.
No matter what interval you pick
here, if you look at the
image for every point
in the image, there
are going to be what?
Two back mappings, two points
that come from here.
The reason I say you have
to be careful is this.
You see, you can have a case
where the curve does this.
It comes in, gets tangent
to the x-axis, and then
goes down like this.
You see, at this particular
point, the
derivative at 0 is 0.
Yet, the curve is still never
falling in this area.
This particular curve is 1:1.
I guess what we're saying here
is that when a derivative is
0, be careful because something
like this can happen.
If the derivative is not 0,
then we know that in the
neighborhood of the point in
question, as long as the curve
is smooth, it represents
a 1:1 function.
And this is what we'll be doing
very, very often in
calculus, is using neighborhoods
of points at
which the derivative is not 0.
Now, what this leads
to is this.
When you start talking about
things like a derivative being
0, and intervals and
one-to-oneness, I think you
can see that this suggests a
rather powerful means or need
for doing the geometry
of curve plotting.
This will be the topic of
our next investigation.
And so until next
time, goodbye.
ANNOUNCER: Funding for the
publication of this video was
provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.